ah doc i broke my arm you gotta help me  oh my god get this man to surgery  hi um i have broken my arm oh my god  [Music]  can't help but feel  it wouldn't have broken if you'd lost  weight you see how the misogyny  basically doesn't exist anymore in our  country  because if it did  you wouldn't have to invent totally  fictional examples of it like this  that would never happen if you come into  the to the doctor with a broken arm as a  woman they're gonna they're gonna elect  you for for being overweight uh besides  obesity can cause broken arms  what if you busted through a trampoline  or something  you know so that can happen but this is  invented misogyny which shows you that  uh that  basically doesn't exist anymore the the  demand just like with hate crimes and  that's how you get justice millet the  demand for misogyny is um  is greater than the supply supply  demand  dude  we used econ